Speaker 1: So, OK, I already told you, 20th
anniversary of 9/11, Bush, Clinton, Biden,
Obama, they went to different events. George W.
Bush gave an interesting speech that contained
some propaganda, but also accurately kind of drew
a line between the 9/11 terrorists and the Trump
writers of January 6th. And we've talked about
that. As I already told you, Trump did boxing
commentary on the 20th anniversary of 9/11. But
here's something that's just extra pathetic.
In pre fight, Trump participated in pre fight
stuff as well, he called in to like a weigh in or
something like that, really, really presidential,
and he said that he would be able to knock out Joe
Biden in seconds. This is one former president
saying he'd be able to beat up another or the
current president and former Vice President
Joe Biden. Well, our country is a joke, right?
It is my perception wrong here, like
we're we're a complete and total joke.
Look at this. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Amazing, this comes from Josh Peter of
USA Today. If you have to box somebody on Saturday
night, who would it be and what would the fight
look like? Yeah, well, I had to pick somebody
in the world, not only a professional boxer,
because I'll take a pass on the professional
boxers. That can be a very dangerous subject. But
if you said do I if I had a box, somebody,
anybody, I think probably my easiest fight would
be Joe Biden, because I would go down very, very
quickly, very, very quickly. And everyone said,
oh, I'd like to take him behind the bar.
He'd be in big trouble if he ever did. Now,
I think Biden would go down within the
first few seconds, the first few seconds.
All right, President Trump, thank you so much
for your time. We will see you on Saturday night.
Speaker 1: Oh, God, guys, I don't I mean.
What how what do what do we say, you know,
when the former president was asked?
If you could box anyone, you know,
who who would it be, and he says, well, I think
if I boxed Joe Biden, it would be really easy
and he would go down within a few seconds. How
pathetic is this stuff? How pathetic is this
stuff? If if Obama had said this about Bush, what
do you think would have been the reaction? I mean,
it's it's just lunacy. We are a joke. And by the
way, I don't know that I even you know, this is
sort of like who would win in a fight, an oversize
dock or tiny horses? You know, those weird things.
I actually think Joe Biden would would crush
Donald Trump. I don't know much about fighting
boxing. You know, we would need to go to other
people. But just based on how Biden gets around
and dogs and bikes and different things and then,
you know, Trump had to be helped down a ramp and
it's just the guy's not in good shape. It
seems to me that Trump is is not a guy who
would do particularly well in a fight. I
don't know. I mean, he's obese and he's is
anyway. Who cares? Not only does Trump appear to
be completely out of his mind with this stuff,
where the first thing is if you fought someone,
who would it be? It'd be Biden. He also seems
to be living in a fantasy world when it comes to
his own strength and his own fitness. And every
day I am this this weekend in particular, you
know, I've often people write in and they say,
David, how do you deal with just all this wacky
news all the time? Isn't it demoralizing? And
and I say, you know, I'm really desensitized
to most of it. I'm just so used to covering
this stuff. The stuff this weekend really pushed
it to a new level where I was actually sitting
there looking at my screen, getting ready for
the show, saying what the hell is going on in
this country right now? Just a humiliating
weekend for the United States on vaccines,
on the stuff Trump is doing, et cetera. And
that's before I even talk about Rudy Giuliani's
seemingly drunk rant at his 9/11 dinner. That's
what we'll start with after this short break